Chris from the future here. I have to
start this video by showing you the
mother of all ESC voltage spikes. Huge
thank you to Luke Maximo Bell for
allowing me to share this clip.
I will remember you.
[Music]
Hi there everyone and welcome back to
the channel. If you've ever had an ESC
spontaneously catch fire, particularly
when you're disarming your drone, or
you've had an ESC catch fire during a
crash, you may have been the victim of a
voltage spike. In this video, I'm going
to be doing a deep dive set of testing
to look at how these voltage spikes come
about, what causes them, and how we can
mitigate them with capacitors and TVS
diodes to try and minimize the chance of
any of our ESC's bursting into flames.
This video is a response to a couple of
questions that I received and also um an
issue that Luke Bell has been facing
with his world record drone where he has
often seen ESC's spontaneously catch
fire, particularly when disarming the
drone. This is going to be a really
interesting video. I've done heaps of
testing. Um I've got lots and lots of
data to share with you. Um so let's not
waste any more time. Let's dive right
into it. So, let me take you through the
equipment that we're going to be using
to make these measurements. Starting
with the motor. This is a 2207 1850 KV
uh 6S FPV motor with a 5x 4.3x3 prop.
So, kind of standard 5 in FPV setup. And
we also have an RPM sensor here so that
we can spin this motor up to exactly the
same RPM for each test. The motor is
connected to a Sky Stars KM55 amp AM32
ESC. And on the battery lead of this
ESC, I've connected two stiff copper
wires, one to the ground and one to the
positive battery voltage. The um ground
lead has the two ground connections for
the oscilloscope probes connected to it.
And I have one oscilloscope probe
connected to the positive battery lead
and one to one of the wires to the motor
so we can measure the voltage on one of
the motor phases. The two uh
oscilloscope probes are connected to
this HEC USB oscilloscope so that we can
log the data and uh gather all of the
information and record it onto the
computer. And then in terms of power, we
have two batteries. I've got a 4S 5000
mAh and a 6S 5000 mAh. And they're both
kept topped up to the right voltage by
this power supply here.
In general, this is pretty
representative of what you get with a
single motor and single ESC. And we are
going to be able to measure the size of
the voltage spikes that we get from u
both the motor just running and also
actively breaking with no capacitor
attached and then with capacitors and
TVS diodes attached to the ESC as well.
And here we have the components that
we're going to be testing on this rig.
We have um a 1000 microfarad capacitor
and a 470 microfarad capacitor. We have
a capacitor with short legs and a
capacitor with the legs left long. And
we also have this fetch spike absorber
which is a set of TVS diodes, transient
voltage suppression diodes which are
also commonly used to try and mitigate
voltage spikes in electronic circuits.
So we'll see how well this works at
mitigating the spikes onc. All right. So
now I'm going to take you through some
live data collection so you can see
exactly how I collected the data that
we're going to be looking at in the rest
of this video. I have my USB
oscilloscope set up on the screen. I
have the test stand set up back here.
I'm only going to be running this at a
very low RPM because obviously um I'm
here recording. Uh normally I would go
and stand away from the whole test setup
while it's running. But we're going to
collect a little bit of data now so you
can see what we're going to be looking
at. So first things first, safety specs
on. And then I'm going to power this up
just with a 4S battery. I don't want to
run it up to high voltages. And you can
see that immediately we start hearing
the ESC beeping. And if I go to the
oscilloscope screen and I bring this
trigger level down, you will actually be
able to see that the oscilloscope is
measuring the beeps. And we can actually
look and find the height of the spike
when the ESC is just beeping. So just
when the ESC is beeping, we haven't got
any capacitor or anything on this. We're
getting up to a spike about 18.5 volts
on a 16vt pack just from the ESC
beeping. Now, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to start the motor spinning
just nice and slowly, and then we can
see what the trace looks like while the
motor is running. So, I'm going to run
the ESC up to just a pretty low speed.
Let's go for
um let's go for 5,000 RPM initially. So,
again, now I can bring down the trigger
level and we can see uh what the ESC
looks like while it's running. And
again, we're getting kind of an
oscillating voltage on the battery lead,
exactly as we would expect. And that
oscillating voltage is looking to be
around 18 volts. Now, if I increase the
RPM of the motor a little
bit, you'll see that the spikes get a
little bit
bigger, but we can kind of get the idea.
The faster the motor is running, the
higher the spike is going to be. Again,
this is without any capacitor or TVS
diode in place.
Now, what we're going to do is we're
going to try and collect some data when
the motor is actively braking. And the
way I'm going to do that is I'm going to
turn the trigger voltage up a little
bit. I'm going to set the trigger mode
to single shot. And now you can see that
we're kind of seeing uh what's going on
with the with the trace, albeit a little
bit slower. Now, I'm going to disarm the
ESC and actively break the
motor. And there you go. The motor has
stopped spinning and the trace has
stopped because we've hit our trigger
point. I'm just going to unplug the ESC,
so it stops
beeping. What you can see is that we
have actually a much bigger spike when
the motor is actively braking than when
it's running. And that's what we're
going to see throughout the rest of this
video. The spike from this motor braking
is just around maybe it peaks at 21
volts. And remember that's 21 volts on a
16volt battery voltage. So we're getting
quite a a big spike over and above the
maximum battery voltage that this ESC
would ever see if you plugged in even a
fully charged pack. It's interesting to
note that as well as obviously the big
spike on the battery leads, we also see
a big spike on the individual motorphase
wires when we're doing this active
braking. So this motorphase is
momentarily hitting a voltage of about
25 volts u which is yeah 9 volts more
than the 16 volts that we're actually
supplying from the battery at this
moment. So it's worth being aware that
you're going to get voltage spikes not
only on the battery leads but also on
the individual motor phases during
active motor braking like this. So, now
that you've seen how I collected all of
this test data, let's dive into the
results and take a look at how these
voltage spikes change depending on RPM,
battery voltage, and how effective
capacitors and TVS dodes are at
mitigating their effects. So, let's
start by looking at the data collected
at 4S battery voltage with no capacitor
and no TVS diode fitted. So, remember
there are still capacitors on the ESC,
but we're just not fitting any extra
ones. Running at 10,000 RPM, um, we get
spikes up to about 20 volts on the
battery lead, and the voltage drops as
low as about 13 volts at the the bottom
of a dip. So, we're getting about a 7V
peakto peak on the battery leads. The
motors are spiking even higher. They're
spiking up to about 22 volts. Um, and
again this is while running at a
16.1volt average battery voltage. If we
then start to break the motor, so we
disarm the ESC for active braking, we
get a spike up to 25 volts on the
battery lead. And we actually don't see
the biggest spike on the motorphase here
because um it's actually that's a
different phase of the motor that we're
not connected to. We do see a spike to
25 volts on the motorphase that we are
measuring. And that's just at 10,000
RPM, which is like probably not even
hover throttle. It's like even below
hover throttle. If we go up to 15,000
RPM, um, now we're getting spikes up to
21 volts on the battery lead. So, those
spikes have got even higher. We're
looking at an 8 and a half volt peak to
peak. And then we see spikes up to 26
volts on our motor phase while the motor
is running. um just at this moment here,
which I guess perhaps is a a measurement
period on the on the drive of the the
motor. I'm not sure. But again, we're
still only at 16.1 volts average battery
voltage. So, we've got spikes up to, you
know, up into the 6S voltage range. Now,
if we look at active braking at 15,000
RPM, so disarming the ESC at 15,000 RPM,
which is um like a hover throttle for a
pretty heavily laden quad would be up at
sort of 15,000 RPM. So, you might disarm
from that level. You're getting spikes
up to 27 12 volts on the battery lead.
um spikes up to 21 volts on the fa motor
phase that we're measuring. But you
know, we can expect higher spikes on the
motor phases that are being actively
break first. And again, this is just on
a 16.2 volt 4S battery voltage. At
20,000 RPM, um spikes to 19 volts,
spikes to 25 volts on the motor phases.
Um bit of a lower average battery
voltage because obviously now we're
drawing a lot more current. And that is
kind of the the competing factor. As you
draw more current, the average voltage
drops, but the size of the the spikes
can still be pretty high. What's really
interesting is when you start breaking
from really high RPMs. Here we're
getting spikes to 28 volts on the
battery lead and we happen to catch the
right motor phase to get the first
braking spike. And that spikes up to 33
volts. So it's more than twice our
average battery voltage is momentarily
being applied onto the FETSS on the ESC
just at the moment where it starts to
break the motor. And you can see that
this spike doesn't last all that long.
Um maybe 10 micros or so. Um but it does
kind of ring away as uh the motor slows
down as the braking takes over and the
motor comes to a
stop. I went up to 25,000 RPM. Um, same
spikes, spikes to 19 volts, spikes to 23
volts on the motor leads. Now we're
we're down at a 15.4 volt average
battery voltage because we're drawing a
lot of current. So, there's voltage sag
from the battery, but we're still
getting spikes up to the same sort of
level that we were getting um at the
lower RPMs just because our peakto peak
is is a little bit bigger.
When we look at the braking for 25,000
RPM, that's where we hit the biggest um
spikes that I measured on 4S voltage.
So, spikes to 30 volts on the battery
leads, spikes to 35 volts on the motor
leg. And again, we just happen to be
fortunate that we catch the start of the
motor braking in this test. So, um the
phase that we're measuring is the first
phase to start measuring uh to start
breaking the motor and therefore gives
us the highest spike. and we've got an
average battery voltage of 15.8 volts.
So, it's we're spiking to way above
twice battery voltage on the motorphase.
If you're interested to look at all of
the raw data from this testing, I'm
going to post it all in a PDF on my
Patreon. So, you can sign up for just a
few dollars a month. And as well as
supporting this channel and helping me
make more videos like this for everyone
in the community, you'll also be able to
download all of that data to look
through it at your leisure. If that
interests you, then please, please check
out the link down in the video
description. So far, so terrifying,
right? I mean, these voltage spikes were
a lot bigger than I was expecting. And
we're still only using 4S battery
voltage. Let's take a look at some of
the more extreme results for 6S. Now, so
now, let's take a look at the most
extreme results on 6S battery voltage,
no capacitor, no TDS diode, and the
highest RPMs. Looking at the 30,000 RPM,
which is pretty much wide open throttle
at this point, we're getting spikes up
to 32 volts and spikes up to 34 volts on
the motor phase while the motor is
actively running. And that's with a 23.1
volts of average battery voltage. If we
then break the motor, we see spikes up
to 44.5 volts on the battery leads. Um,
spikes to 28 volts on the motor. And
it's interesting to note here that with
the 6S testing, the voltage starts to
dip at the start of the motor braking,
whereas on 4S, the voltage always rised
at the start of the motor braking. Um,
I'm not sure exactly why this is.
Perhaps someone who's familiar with
motor commutation would be able to
explain it, but it seems like the peak
occurs just after the start of the
braking rather than
um like immediately when the motor
starts to break. Average battery
voltage, 23.8 volts during this test.
So, we're getting spikes up to not quite
um double the battery voltage, but
pretty close on the battery leads. And I
can imagine that um the motorphases
could even potentially spike higher than
the battery leads. Um although obviously
it's very hard to catch that actually
happening. We're going to start by
looking at the 470 microfarad low ESR
capacitor that's supplied with most 20x
20 and 30x30 ESC's. And I've mounted it
by cutting the legs as short as possible
and soldering it directly onto the
battery pads of the KM55 amp ESC. So,
this is kind of the ideal mounting
situation for a capacitor where it
should be able to do the most good. So,
I'm going to skip over the low RPM tests
because they're not super interesting
and jump straight to 20,000 RPM. Now,
we've done exactly the same test but
with the 470 microfarad capacitor with
short legs soldered across the battery
leads. And it makes a huge difference to
the size of the voltage spikes. We see
when the motor is just running at 20,000
RPM, we barely get any spikes. We've got
a 15.8 volt average and a spike on the
battery leads up to 16 1.5 volts. That
is totally different to what we saw
without any capacitor. It really really
reduces the level of that spike. And
honestly, there's there's very little
fluctuation in battery voltage.
Interestingly, we do still see spikes on
the motor leads. And although those
spikes are now to a much lower level, um
those spikes up to about 19.5 volts in
this case are still significantly above
the voltage that we see on the battery
leads. So um we still do have to be
somewhat concerned about the voltage
that individual motor phases might be
reaching when uh the motor is running
even if we put a capacitor across the
battery leads. Obviously 58 volt average
for this test. If we now move on to the
braking um we see again a vast
improvement. I mean we're talking about
now having spikes of just a couple of
volts up to about 18 volts and the uh
motors are spiking up to 22 1/2 volts.
So the motors are still spiking up to a
higher voltage than battery voltage um
by quite a significant way. But the
amount of spike is just completely
different to what we saw without any
capacitor in place. So the capacitor is
reducing the size of the spikes both on
the battery terminals and also on the
motor phases. If we look at 25,000 RPM
um again we don't really see much in the
way of spikes when the motor is running
uh on the battery leads. On the
individual motor phases, we're getting
spikes up to 21 volts,
which although it's a lot higher than 16
volts, it's still nowhere near what we
were seeing without a capacitor. And we
got a 15.3 volt average um just because
the motors under more load, drawing more
current on the 25,000 RPM braking, we
kind of get a a perfect worst case test
where we catch the first motor phase
that is breaking the motor. We get a
spike here up to 24 volts on the
motorphase, but the battery voltage only
spikes to about 17 1.5 volts. So, you
can see that that at this point, if
we've got that capacitor with short legs
soldered across the battery leads, we
probably don't need to worry about um
spikes in battery voltage anymore. That
seems to be well handled, but we might
still want to worry about spikes on the
individual motor phases, particularly if
we're running at much, much higher
voltages. One of the things that pilots
are often concerned about, and I think
justifiably so, is the length of the
legs on the capacitor that they solder
to the ESC. Obviously, there's a concern
that if you make the legs too long, the
resistance of the wire between the ESC
and the capacitor reduces its
effectiveness. To test this, I did a
test with the capacitor leaving the legs
as long as possible to see how much that
affected the efficacy of the capacitor
at smoothing out those voltage spikes.
So here we're looking at exactly the
same test setup and same test method.
And actually the same 470 microfarad
capacitor, but this time the legs are 20
mm long rather than as short as
possible. So they're left as as long as
they can be. What we see is that we do
get a bit of a degradation in
performance with the longer capacitor
legs, but the degradation is not
massive. We're looking at between a half
and one volt of increase in the size of
the spike on the battery leads by
leaving the legs to 20 mm long. So we're
getting a spike to about 17 volts at
20,000 RPM. Um a spike to 22 volts on
the motorphase and that's with a 15.9
volt average voltage. If we then look at
the braking again, we see a bit of a
bigger spike. So 18.5 volts rather than
18, but it's it's not a big increase in
the size of the spike at all. and a
similar size of spike on the motor
leads. And the same is true at 25,000
RPM um 17 volt 21.5 volts on a 15.4
average. And uh the braking test, we get
a spike up to 18 volts uh with a a
motorphase spike up to 23 volts. Again,
this is the the worst case because we
caught the first phase. And that's on a
16V average battery voltage. So yeah,
based on this testing, I don't think we
need to be overly concerned about
leaving the legs of the capacitor just a
little bit longer. It doesn't seem to
degrade performance all that much, but I
would suggest that it is overall better
practice to try and keep the legs of
that capacitor nice and short. And if
you do need to make the legs longer,
consider using some leftover motor wire
or something like that so that when you
extend the capacitor legs, you're using
thicker wire with a lower resistance.
But overall based on this, we shouldn't
expect to see a a huge degradation in
performance just from having slightly
longer legs on our capacitors. Here's
the data from the thousand microfarad
capacitor. And overall, I really didn't
see any improvement in performance
moving from a 470 microfarad up to a,000
microfarad capacitor. In this testing,
we might be well into the region of
diminishing returns, but we can see that
we get a spike to 24.5 on battery
voltage while the motor is running at
25,000 RPM. Um, a spike on the
motorphase to 32 volts, and that's with
a 23.6 volt average. Under braking, we
spike up to 26 volts um with an
individual motorphase spiking up to 33
volts. And that's on a 24volt average.
Honestly, I couldn't see much difference
in performance between the 470 and the
thousand microfarads. Um perhaps if you
had many more motors, you had four
motors on the ESC rather than just one
and you were breaking all of them at the
same time, um you might see a benefit
from the the thousand, but I couldn't
see anything for the 470. So, capacitors
work really well on the battery leads,
but there is another way to mitigate
voltage spikes, which we haven't talked
about yet. So, for those of you not
familiar with TVS diodes, this is a
quick explainer. This is a FET spike
absorber, and you can see it's got three
components on it, and they are three TVS
diodes or transient voltage suppression
diodes. They're zenoid dodes, um, which
this is the electrical circuit symbol
for them. And what they do is they help
manage spikes in voltage. So without any
TVS diode present, let's say we have a
spike in voltage coming along. So we got
our battery voltage and then suddenly we
break our motor and we get a big spike
like that. And we're worried that the
top of this spike is going to be such a
high voltage that it might damage
components and you know that could be
really bad for our ESC.
So, we have this thing called a TVS
diode. And with a TVS diode, you use it
a little bit differently to a regular
diode. Normally, you would apply
positive voltage on this side of the
diode and it would flow through the
diode. That's how like LEDs and stuff
work. But with a TVS diode or a Zen
diode, you actually apply voltage the
other way. So, you apply positive
voltage here and the diode doesn't
conduct electricity. So, it just sort of
um is an is a an
insulator. As this voltage builds up and
up and up, eventually it reaches a point
that's called the breakdown voltage of
this diode. At this point, the diode can
no longer resist the reverse bias, the
reverse voltage, and it breaks down. And
it does that really really fast. It
breaks down in in nanconds or even
picosconds.
and a huge amount of electrical current
is suddenly able to flow from the
positive to the negative side because we
got this big uh reverse voltage and
suddenly this diode breaks down and
conducts really really
well. As soon as this voltage falls back
below the breakdown voltage, the diode
stops conducting again. And this has the
effect of basically chopping the top off
this spike. So the voltage is coming
along, it spikes up, it hits the
breakdown voltage of the diode. The
diode conducts really well. A lot of
current flows through the diode and the
voltage is unable to climb any higher
and stays at that level until um the
spike is finished and then obviously
comes back down again. And this level
here is called the breakdown voltage
level of the diode. So this approach we
can use to mitigate the spikes on the
battery leads of our ESC by soldering
the uh zeno diode across the battery
leads in such a way that the positive
voltage is applying reverse bias to the
diode. So now we've talked through how
these TVS dodes work. Let's see how they
perform in practice. So all of these
tests are conducted at 6S voltage. We're
going to start with the 10,000 RPM. You
can see that we are getting um spikes to
27 volts when we have just the TVS diode
in place with no capacitor. So you can
see that that's pretty similar to what
we were getting um when running 6S
voltage with no capacitor and no diodes.
We also see spikes to 29 volts on the
motor phases. When we move to breaking
uh we see a spike up to 30.5 volts, but
you can see that the spike is no longer
a sort of nice uh decaying sinosoidal
spike. We now have this sort of weird
little um shape here, this little step.
Now, obviously, it's not a perfect uh
chop of the top of the peak like I
showed in my drawing, but as you'll see,
this is this is already has a TVS diode
starting to work. You can see that it
helps cut the spike, but it's still
reaching about 30.5 volts. So, it's a
lot higher than what we have with the
capacitor. and we'd see an even bigger
spike on the motorphase because
obviously the motorphase can spike up
even a little bit higher than what we
see on the battery leads. If we go to
15,000 RPM again, we see that we're now
getting uh still spikes up to 30 volts
and up to 29.5 volts on the motorphase.
And during braking at 15,000 RPM, we can
see the spike spikes a little bit
higher. But now that change in shape is
starting to become even more obvious.
we've got a a kind of little spike and
then suddenly the spike kind of stops
and comes back down and then stays at
this level. That is the TVS diode kind
of cutting in, breaking down and
starting to conduct and it basically
chops the top off that spike. So that
keeps it to about 32 volts at a maximum
with obviously a a kind of breakdown
voltage here of somewhere around 30
volts. It doesn't stop the motor phases
spiking up pretty high though. We're
still seeing spikes up to 38.5 volts on
the motorphase, but the shape again is
different because uh you can see the the
conduction of the TVS diode here is kind
of chopping the top off what would
otherwise be a nice rounded kind of top
of a
sinosoid. At 20,000 RPM, we got spikes
up to 30 volts, spikes to 29 12 volts on
the motor phases. But then under
braking, even though we're at a higher
RPM, we don't see a higher spike. spike
still gets up to about 31 volts. You can
see it being cut off both in the battery
leads and in the motor phases as well.
This keeps going. We go to 25,000 RPM
and you can see that we're getting now
spikes up to 30 volts just when the
motor is running. Um spikes to 36 volts
on the motor phases. But under braking
again, you know, only up to about 32
volts. So we keep increasing the RPM. We
keep increasing the expected size of the
spike, but that spike doesn't actually
materialize because the TVS diode kind
of clamps the top of it and that voltage
just dies away.
However, we are not getting anywhere
near the performance that we saw with
the capacitor because we're still
getting spikes up to 32 volts whereas
before we were seeing only spikes of up
to sort of 26 volts and we're seeing
commensurately much higher
spikes on the motorphase as well even
though the TVS diode is doing its job
and conducting
uh to kind of chop the top off the peak.
So, what conclusions can we draw from
all of this testing and all of this
data? Well, I think the first is that
definitely don't find yourself in the
position where you are running an ESC
without the supplied capacitor soldered
onto it. Um, the spikes that we were
seeing are at least double battery
voltage if you don't have a TVS or you
don't have a capacitor soldered onto
your ESC. And there's only so much abuse
the effects on an ESC are going to take
before all of that overvoltage just
starts to degrade them and eventually
they will fail. When they fail, they
usually fail short circuit and that's
going to burn the ESC and cause the quad
to fall out of the sky. So definitely
don't run an ESC without a capacitor
soldered to it. Um try and keep the legs
of the capacitor short, but you know
it's it's not the end of the world if
they happen to be just a little bit
longer. The main thing is they fit
nicely in your build and you have that
capacitor soldered on. A capacitor on
the battery leads is going to be doing a
much better job than just a TVS diode. A
lot of modern ESC's actually like this
um this T-mo F55 Pro 3 actually come
with a TVS diode on the board. Um I
don't think that's going to do anything
if you also have a capacitor soldered to
the board. What it will do is provide
some protection for the ESC in the event
that someone runs it without a cap
because then the TVS diode can step in
and kind of chop the tops off those
peaks and and help avoid overvolting the
whole ESC. But if you've got a capacitor
soldered onto the ESC and that capacitor
is working correctly, um, then the TVS
diode probably isn't doing anything.
It's good to have it there though
because if the capacitor fails or comes
off the board, then the TVS diode is
your fall back and it's going to protect
the ESC um help you get to the end of
the flight and then you'll spot that
something's wrong with the cap, repair
it or replace it and you won't burn the
ESC. In the event that you're trying to
do something really really extreme with
your ESC, uh for example, you're going
for um a world drone speed record, then
uh certainly you you're going to want a
lot of capacitance on the ESC. Um
certainly you're going to want a TVS
diode on the ESC in the event that the
spikes are even more than the capacitors
can deal with. But I think there's
another thing to think about which is
the voltage spikes on the individual
motor phases.
That can also be a problem because if
those get super big um they can get a
lot lot bigger than the spikes that you
see on the battery leads. So the the
battery lead spikes will be at some
level the um motor phases could spike to
an even higher level than that. It's not
appropriate to try and solder capacitors
across the motor phases um because if
you put capacitance on there it's going
to mess up the the ESC driving the motor
cause all sorts of problems. But you
could consider using TVS diodes um
across the motor phases with a suitable
breakdown voltage um that's just a bit
less than the breakdown voltage of the
FETSS on the ESC so that in the event
that you get a big voltage spike on the
motorphases um the TVS diode can step in
conduct away a bit of that spike and
just protect the fetss on the ESC um
that might help prevent some of the
pretty extreme ESC fires I've seen where
drones have disarmed and just burst into
flames. In any case, I really hope
you've enjoyed this deep dive and that
you've got some useful learnings from
it. Um, certainly I really enjoyed
making the video. I hope you enjoyed
watching it. That's all I have for you
until next time. So, until then, I wish
you all very, very happy flying.
[Music]